E aí
[Música]
eu era uma manhã fria na Serra da
Cantareira
eu sai para tomar café com meu filho ele
tinha uns 12 anos na época a gente Tomou
café e aí ele saiu correndo para o
Jardim foi lá brincar com os cachorros
balançar sobre as árvores eu tava super
atrasada que estava trabalhar você tava
tomar um banho e já fazer um beijo que
eu dormia em um quarto separado
é mas eu precisava ir para o banheiro
tomar um banho e eu tinha que atravessar
um corredor que passava pelo quarto do
casal e era uma tortura atravessar
aquele corredor
aquele corredor me fazer lembrar
aquele tapa que eu recebi quando eu tava
grávida
aquele corredor me fez lembrar
daquele dia que ele deu um soco no
para-brisa do carro para não me atingir
aquele corredor me fazer lembrar das
várias humilhações
no desse bem
em caso de Alpha de várias discussões da
frente das pessoas dos nossos amigos e
ele sempre me dizia fica quieta quando
um burro fala o outro abaixa a orelha
eu cheguei lá no banheiro tomei um banho
ele não se importou de entrar ali
e que eu tava no lugar no momento íntimo
às vezes ele até esbarravam no meu ombro
de propósito para marcar território
foram 12 anos de relacionamento Nós
estávamos em fase de separação
o nosso caso tava com uma advogada
resolvendo a guarda da criança as
cláusulas né da guarda da criança em
relação também a pensão em relação as
visitas
Oi e ele me dizia que ele não ia abrir
mão de guarda nenhuma
ele não tinha mais a mulher e não tinha
mais a mulher mas ele tinha o filho
e para ele era uma questão de poder era
uma disputa o filho era uma disputa para
ele reafirmar a sua autoridade naquele
relacionamento era uma forma de me
atingir
e o tom da sua voz eu já sentia já
sentia o peso daquele ódio eu já ficava
com medo porque me fazia lembrar de
muitos momentos e que culminaram em
alguma agressão maior
eu já senti aquele tom já me dava aquela
sensação de encurralada aquele homem de
1,92
o barbado
Partiu para cima de mim mas eu não ia
levar o outro Papa eu consegui correr eu
corri eu corri
peguei a minha mala fiz a minha mala
peguei o meu filho Esperei ele sair para
trabalhar e fui por uma delegacia
e nesses 12 anos de relacionamento muita
gente muita gente me dizia que era um
amor Latino quero um amor quente que ele
me amava porque eram muitas flores nas
vezes que a gente brigava eram os
arrependimentos os pedidos de perdão eu
já perdi as contas de quantos ciclos da
violência nós passamos desses 12 anos as
pessoas
romantiza vão a violência as pessoas vão
analisavam a dor e eu também era um
vício eu me senti escrava daquela
relação na verdade a violência
psicológica me escravizou naquela
relação
e eu não fui a única
e eu não fui a primeira e nem a última
do Brasil que sofreu um tipo de
violência o como é
estima-se que no Brasil
e é que o Brasil seja o quinto no mundo
que mais mata mulheres estão atrás de El
Salvador Guatemala
dando atrás da Rússia
já estima-se e apenas no ano nos últimos
12 meses
17 milhões de mulheres acima de 16 anos
sofreram algum tipo de violência física
sexual psicológica
pasmem acima de 16 anos e significa que
amazonense que começa cedo
estima-se também que seja uma violência
praticada por cerca de oitenta por cento
de pessoas com quem a vítima tem o teve
relacionamento íntimo
Esse é um tipo de violência
imobilizou uma ao EA organização dos
Estados americanos
a condenar a responsabilizar o Brasil
pela tolerância à violência doméstica e
familiar contra a mulher a Lei Maria da
Penha veio na minha época não tinha Lei
Maria da Penha e ela veio para coroar
e é uma luta do movimento das mulheres
essa lei considerada pela ONU a terceira
melhor do mundo no enfrentamento à
violência contra a mulher é uma lei que
diz o seguinte que violação a direitos
humanos se violência doméstica é uma
violação a Direitos Humanos é uma lei
que dia o ali enterrar a ideia de que um
tapinha não dói dói bem o enterrar a
ideia de que a violência deve ser
analisada bem um enterrar a ideia de que
quem briga de marido e mulher não se
mete a colher porque é preciso meter a
colher vem um enterrar a ideia de que
mulher gosta de apanhar A culpa não é da
vítima
essa lei prevê Quatro Pilares o seu
enfrentamento enfrentamento da violência
quais são eles
assistência À Vítima
i a proteção À Vítima mulheres passam de
violência prevê também a repressão sim é
preciso reprimir a violência mas também
previa a prevenção da violência eu gosto
de dizer que esses Pilares não funcionam
sozinho na verdade sozinhos eles
religião mas não enfrenta a violência
doméstica
essa lei ela veio romper uma cultura
brasileira
essa lei que comer three veio um ano de
dois mil e gente um
romper comemorar os seus 15 anos de
existência apesar disso existe um dado
de que 51 por cento das pessoas
viram alguma mulher sofrer violência na
sua frente e da pandemia a cada minuto
oito mulheres sofreram violência não é
qualquer tipo de violência nós não
estamos falando de uma briga de bar nós
estamos falando de uma violência que
acontece em casa entre quatro paredes
Inclusive a ONU considera a casa um
perigo para as mulheres a casa o lugar
mais provável para ela ser morta Lógico
que eu estou falando de situações em que
ao relacionamento abusivo e
bom então dados assustadores que mostram
que é um tipo de violência é considerada
uma epidemia
é uma aí pdma é um tipo de violência e
que a mulher só se só se em silêncio e
que ela acontece de forma reiterada
muitas mulheres passam um anos vivendo
violência psicológica se sentindo
culpada
entendendo que contribuíram de alguma
forma para crio porque elas aprenderam
que assim que se vive que assim que
ocorre esta dinâmica a lei veio romper
com isso
eu vou te contar mais uma característica
da esse tipo de violência é uma
violência que adoece e causa sofrimento
tanto é que a própria Organização
Mundial de Saúde reconhece que é um caso
de saúde pública
a Organização Mundial de Saúde
reconhece que é um tipo de violência que
causa duas vezes a chance de acometer as
mulheres com depressão
Esse é um tipo de violência que o
próprio Banco Mundial
concluiu que há mais risco das mulheres
sofrem violência doméstica no que pasmem
aconteceu acidente de trânsito
Tá bom eu sou promotora de Justiça há 23
anos que Faculdade de Direito em
Guarulhos e lá na faculdade eu comecei a
fazer estágio do ministério público e eu
tinha um sonho de ser promotora de
Justiça o Ministério Público ganhou
atribuições pastilhas possível de
transformar a vida das pessoas de
defender a ordem democrática de defender
os direitos fundamentais os direitos
fundamentais das pessoas das mulheres a
Lei Maria da Penha inclusive prever uma
gama Ampla de atribuições do Ministério
Público a única instituição que tem
atribuição em todas as tralhas atua em
todos os processos onde a mulheres em
situação de violência fiscaliza os
serviços de atendimento às mulheres em
situação de violência
articula políticas públicas Inclusive
tem a responsabilidade de cadastrar os
casos de violência doméstica e familiar
contra a mulher e eu percebi que como
promotora de Justiça de enfrentamento à
violência contra a mulher era preciso
sair do gabinete e veio lá trás do curso
que eu fiz um Núcleo de Estudos da
violência da USP o projeto de prevenção
reconhecendo a estratégia de saúde da
família como um serviço como a um lugar
estratégico e assim dizer o nome para
prevenir a violência doméstica e
familiar contra a mulher ou primeiro
esse a estratégia é considerada pelo
mundo uma das melhores políticas de
prevenção de doenças e agravos
nós sabemos que no Brasil chega atingir
o programa 110 milhões de brasileiros
110 milhões e significa que milhares de
agentes de saúde saem às ruas todos os
dias para prevenir agravos para prevenir
o adoecimento
vamos lembrar a violência contra a
mulher acontece de forma reiterada
agentes comunitários de saúde visitam a
causa dessas pessoas continuadamente
violência contra a mulher as mulheres
ficam em silêncio
agentes comunitários de saúde
conseguem a estabeleçam um vínculo com
as cadastradas que assim Cristiano um
romper com o silêncio estabelecer um
diálogo
existe todo um comprometimento é de
levar informações das cadastradas e
contribuir na relação desta cadastrada
como serviço de saúde e com a ampliação
do seu atendimento perante a rede de
atendimento
através desse projeto nós tiramos a
Guarulhos
Guarulhos o Ministério Público de São
Paulo fez uma parceria com a prefeitura
envolvendo as áreas da Saúde Assistência
Social e Coordenadoria das mulheres até
se tornou lei em Guarulhos nós fizemos e
nas regiões nos quatro bairros um dia
mais violência doméstica e familiar
contra a mulher em Guarulhos dos bairros
de pimentas Cabo Sul Cumbica e Bom
Sucesso atingindo 13 unidades básicas de
saúde
todos esses 240 profissionais que
receberam a capacitação receberão
material uma cartilha especializada
desenvolvida pelo programa receberão 60
mil cartilhas para atender a 60 mil
famílias que eles atendem e eles
aprenderam muita coisa eles aprenderam a
conhecer os meandros da violência
doméstica e familiar contra a mulher
aprenderam os instrumentos de me dicos
aprenderam O que é rede eu lembro de um
agente de saúde que me disse o seguinte
Agora eu vou começar a ensinar a minha
filha e que ela não precisa encontrar o
herói que ela precisa ser a heroína das
suas próprias vidas eu tive uma agente
de saúde que disse o seguinte
quando a boca Cala o corpo adoece quando
a boca fala o corpo Sara eu lembro de
uma outra agente de saúde e disse o
seguinte eu resolvi lutar pela minha
liberdade e ela disse isso porque ela
percebeu que aquela realidade também fez
parte da sua vida assim como muitas
outras da gente de saúde até porque
noventa porcento da estratégia de saúde
da família formada por mulheres e ela
disse que resolveu lutar pela sua
liberdade foi essa frase que me trouxe
até aqui
e eu lembro de olhar para o meu filho e
dizer você não vai viver nesse ambiente
de violência
eu disse para ele
e você vai ser um outro homem
tu tem Maio
e foi uma força lá do útero
o que tem seu tomar uma postura postura
da virada eu sei que enfrentar a
violência contra a mulher é um processo
mas aquele dia aconteceu comigo Três
Palavrinhas femininas me impulsionaram
e a saúde
a justiça EA liberdade e agora eu quero
propor um desafio para você qual é o seu
dia da Virada
E aí
[Música]